four to shoot Wiggins has to go Wiggins
pull-up jumper no towns a rebound budget
fly and Carl Anthony towns drills it at
the buzzer a catastrophic finish for the
Grizzlies here's another look
Townes what great awareness to get him
out of his hands and he got it away in
time they will count the bucket Lopez
just a beautiful ball fake there and
then go top shelf use the closest one
came up to a contested Rose loses the
baskets left man Brogdon get that shot
out here died LA the loose ball welcome
project
- damage
[Music]
[Applause]
who's that pressure against him kind of
liked a martial arts move use their
aggressiveness against them there's luck
somebody highlights it's hard to keep up
roster he just takes this takes it to
the classic tough city this is got a
touch of in here comes up with its death
wide in LaMarcus going out for that
block you push it the opposite direction
tomorrow sucks in the entire defense and
my toe on the brain
[Music]
three-point attempt to the season he's
Doug Begley in the hole right back at
you Timberwolves
hilts and early 12-point lead but the
teams right now are coming roaring back
karl-anthony towns leading also I want
more a quick shot by LaMarcus Aldridge
this year on an offensive rebound the
shot clock goes to 14 seconds and set it
back to 24 Forbes back to town sees it
[Applause]
slices it this by a third right here has
a chance to go to the free-throw line
here
slice it in half it's also on for the
Timberwolves great seal there from
LaMarcus on towns and again LA to big if
you're gonna foul every better wrap them
up like they did burger but he was on a
bitching minimum Tyson Chandler JaVale
McGee gets the bucket at the damaged
towns this was impressive held Phoenix
239 and a half the world's a butcher
challenge
[Applause]
tense up a second to go about that it
just buried Anthony Davis underneath the
rim it's a nice capacitive left-hand
just Mary is Davis underneath the basket
for a pretty putback
Andrew Wiggins right behind him at 5.7
Charlotte's comes up with the basketball
Tyus Jones leaves
[Music]
the mail they're heard of Muffit lettuce
but i've never actually had one all
these nice young players like these
players that you go to the front of the
room in town finds him fancy but it's so
effective again towns just off the block
and he creeks and has so much in the
birds average one away to about their
average Portland averages one twelve
point seven charge was the one in the
corner momentarily tab says I'll just
handle it from here
that was crazy
going back to town look at the defenders
who are coming to collapse on towns and
he just hammers it down on them that's
that's an impressive play aggressive
gene unanswered taking a four point lead
in pushing it to LaMarcus Aldridge
7650 seven-game their largest lead of
the night
what pass over the shoulder by town
still cutting charge
sire this runs right into the chest of
Julius Randle again nice cutting because
moving deflection why not shoot it
Marius again another steal and here is
done inside four towns the nation Wow
my goodness DeRozan
well Marcus the three lemarcus gets it
off just in time line is awfully close
six advantage of the quarter so far
[Music]
close out the quarter
[Applause]
two away yep it's all over she was 50
clefts the defense and you've got a lot
of yellow jerseys right there to be on
the key to come right in the face
no kicks with the Miss Belinelli back to
Aldrich man the hammer and a foul
Aldridge he takes a beating here he
tries to go up there and block the shot
kind of half-hearted and LA too big and
too strong about this one throws it down
[Music]
town gets around oh my goodness
karl-anthony towns this is no baseline
underneath the blue thing felt
unbelievable
Westbrook has 12 assists
piece one big football shoe T 3
and really saw hey this guy's gonna have
an impact in this league and he - his
towns finally gets on the board
[Applause]
to take it oh my goodness is he shot the
ball well Bayless finally gets it into
town Oh
elevates it but that just destroys the
rim right now karl-anthony towns in the
tip rolls on the short end of a
six-point game
Palmer's was the double-team come from
the baseline side to Becca
Lucas Aldrich is at the last 10 points
for San Antonio yeah he absolutely just
threw it off the glass to go get it heat
vision in towns and maybe even double
off the post
and wrote it down see that's what makes
me want to play it's those type of plays
that make you miss basketball you want
interspersed a little longer so
dangerous
[Music]
[Applause]
Derek white widely 5 to shoot down
attacking go bad it does slam it down
world there he just put that on the deck
and with the left hand
[Music]
bought into him don't you can't allow
him to go first he feels it to pick us
try to kill him Coco ghee has made have
come as the confidence to part man oh my
goodness
confidence not a problem for Karl at the
towns gets hammered as he throws down
the jam in towns they don't want to go
here in the third it's last night of his
defense tonight offense struggling get
go get this team started this is 80s and
90s this old-school ladies and gentlemen
get him down the low block just get
physical throw your body into the
defender the only would back them up a
few times and I am NOT man Adam
excellent job by pulling it out there
and hedge on Andrew Wiggins get back to
his own town try to take advantage with
yoki side of the game just infused basic
public orbs back to LA he toes the line
hits the three ball Obama I don't think
there's any question now just in the
nick of time town oh my goodness that
was devastated karl-anthony towns did
his best to keep the Timberwolves close
[Applause]
here comes the time to lose it
just about to say picked up by settings
[Music]
[Applause]
and then in transition the reach back
Katmandu ticking the clock you had to
let that one fly if you want to get an
extra shot here with some Stella beef
ribs our big concern about the problem
is the schedules not gonna get in no 6
on the shot clock for right back to
DeRozan la with 2 seconds and we'll
begin on the basketball Bartman moment
there of course the stakes not nearly as
high speaking of high man did he get up
for that slam away from the Wizards
because we wouldn't see this play
that was unbelievable the extension by
karl-anthony towns was best for them
DeRozan misses their ultra quit the
throwdown DeRozan hit the free throw
after the three second defensive
violation that's gonna be on bzees dogs
right back at it cat on the update
karl-anthony towns listen to the
broadcast he's trying to prove something
out here second quarter he goes baseline
Hawley pushes white coach pop loves
Derrick white guys a smooth customer
allows the play to develop comes off the
pick and roll balls only plays of
warriors in this building one time last
season
[Applause]
phlex like that though karl-anthony
towns slinging and the walls with the
six-point advantage early in quarter
number one an awkward rebound their cuts
a brutal day off guard and both right in
the hands of Gordon Hayward oh what a
pass inside four times and then the slam
from LA rudy Gay
starting that action pass to Dom's
Burton's the back screen from marco
belinelli and then the no looker
[Applause]
potatoes Dickon I came on green he's
just a tremendous defender times fits
back to the floor
and who gets the and secures the rebound
off the towns block Loffler swatted away
by white and he comes up for the loose
one Derrick and traffic looking for all
breach finds him and his foul with
Kimball Walker and it's almost identical
you have the UH Kopernik over at the
left Eric white stays in it comes up at
the block up Sprint's to be anytime they
are not gonna let karl-anthony towns for
David post up situations notch it's one
of room taxes get out of here rookie
karl-anthony towns he knows he knows
that Luca wants to get to the rim and do
something spectacular Karl in pursuit
just meets him at the top mission of 22
[Music]
nice job blowing the basket and JAXA
system on that rotation tried to sneak
in there just in time to commit the foul
he's gonna get double figures points and
he has the ball so much most likely
[Applause]
[Music]
unbelievable
hammered on captor made basket and how
about off of a made basket good job of
throwing the ball ahead
towns finishing over Adams take that
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content